i've been talking to some co-workers
recently and i realized that they didn't
realize what i thought was was fairly
public knowledge so i i've decided to
make a video on it and this really just
the fact that hank paulson um when he
became treasury secretary actually got a
pretty good deal actually even when it
happened i wondered you know why would
the ceo of goldman sachs join an
administration that had a traditionally
weak
treasury secretary enjoyed it for the
last really last year of the
administration and this is an article
from a wall street journal market watch
dated june 30th 2006. i don't know how
much you can see it i know the the text
quality definitely degrades when it goes
to youtube
but it's pretty much just saying that
when you become treasury secretary to
avoid a conflict of interest you quote
unquote have
to sell your shares
have to sell
right because
you essentially don't want to be
treasure secretary and also own a huge a
bunch of a large stake in a company and
so let's just read this together paulson
file to sell 3.23 million shares and a
shelf offering of goldman sachs stock
according to prospectus filed with
regulators based on the bank's closing
price of 152 dollars the stock is worth
about 492
million dollars
right so he sold 500 million dollars so
there's one i guess benefit of becoming
the treasury secretary is that you can
offload your stock and it won't raise
any questions because normally if you're
a ceo of a company and you were just
offload all of your stock if you were to
offload 500 million dollars onto the
market people would use to view that as
a huge uh
red flag on the company and you probably
and and the stock would just trade down
and you would get less value for it it
would just be bad for investors in
general but if you say hey i'm going to
become the treasury sector i have to
sell these these shares then all of a
sudden it doesn't look as bad but the
real i guess benefit to what he got is
this rule and let me take it down go
down here
see
it goes here right here interestingly
under u s government ethics rules while
paulson is required to sell the shares
he is also exempt from paying taxes on
any capital gains on the sale if he
obtains a certificate of divestiture the
rule granting the
exception is designed to make sure
government make sure prospective
government employees who own a lot of
stock are not dissuaded from joining the
government
and then the next line is interesting
earlier this week the economist magazine
estimated the rule eliminated a tax
liability of about
200 million dollars for paulson and just
to be clear and and i'm not an expert on
the tax code here
it allows him so it does it limited this
liability if i was a ceo of a company
and if i wasn't treasury secretary and
if i sold all my shares because no one
wants their entire net worth to be
sitting in the stock of one company as
we now learned you know if this was even
goldman sachs shares dropped a lot you
want to diversify your holding so if i'm
a ceo and i want to retire and i want to
diversify my holdings into other things
i'm going to have to pay
if if i sell 200 million dollars of
stock of 500 million dollars of stock
that has a very low cost basis i
essentially paid nothing for it i'm
gonna have to pay 200 million dollars
but if i become treasury secretary for
essentially what june 2006
until what uh january 2008 so
essentially for 18 months work
i can avoid a 200 million dollar or at
least i can defer well just by
diversifying i i avoid the 200 million
dollar tax penalty and then it actually
does get deferred so let's say he takes
that 500 million dollars and he sells
all his goldman shares and he puts it
into treasuries
ten years into the future when he sells
those treasuries my understanding is he
will have to still pay the capital gains
tax but what's interesting about that is
a tax deferral really is a savings
because
i could either pay 200 million dollars
now
right that's what would happen to anyone
else who isn't becoming treasury
secretary or i can defer the taxes let's
say you defer it 10 years into the
future so you pay 200 in you know in 10
years and you could probably defer it
more i mean this is going to go into his
estate and this is enough money that
many generations of paulson's can live
very happily without contributing much
to the world but in 10 years they if he
decides to sell whatever he you know
diversifies into
and even then if he has to pay 200
million at that point
the present value of that 200 million
depending what you discounted at if you
discounted it you know six or seven
percent which i think is a reasonable
rate considering what he probably could
get in other investments but you might
want to discount it by something less
but the present value of that is really
something on the order of about 100
million so no matter how you look at it
for about 18 months of work
18 months of work paulson
essentially got to defer a 200 million
dollar tax liability or you could almost
you could
and even if you say well it's just a
deferral and he's gonna have to pay it
eventually the present value savings of
that is at least 100 million dollars so
just by becoming treasury secretary for
18 months he almost got paid more than
any one of his uh i believe it was seven
or eight years at goldman sachs and then
a a kind of a more uh conspiratorial
view on why he decided to do this above
and if as if the hundred million dollars
or the 200 million dollars depending how
you view it wasn't enough or even just
the ability to diversify your holdings
without creating a big red flag is that
he was ceo of goldman sachs from 1999
where he says it right here he was the c
ceo of goldman sachs in may 1999
you know
he only made 35 million dollars a year
which we all know is peanuts relative to
at least his his his actual holdings in
the stock but this is a little bit of a
ridiculous number too i'd be ceo of
goldman sachs for
for
30 million
but anyway
but so
you know if you wanted to be a little
bit more
more uh
sinister about his motivations then you
could also say that he was ceo from 1999
until 2006
which is exactly
the time period where a lot of the mess
that we're trying to unwind right now
was essentially created
right and goldman sachs was a very
central figure in a lot of this and if
you are the the treasury secretary it
allows you a a unique position to create
some of these uh these bailouts so that
you can essentially cover up a lot of
the the damage that was done by by you
and your your fellow executives over
this seven year period anyway i just
wanted to point this out i thought it
was common knowledge but i realize it's
not because you know i know financial
professionals my co-workers who didn't
know about this and i think it's an
important thing to realize
especially
considering the power he has had
in the last 18 months not only did he
have that power which allowed him to
essentially cover not cover up but well
maybe depending on what you view his
motivations but he also got compensated
quite nicely for his uh for his efforts